like valves of order flows I can't Mike
as the sound of the applause please take
over the mic
[Applause]
okay hey Kathy thanks for uh thanks for
having me hey everybody happy was a
Thursday 25th of June and you know
another crazy change in the market but
hopefully after a faes presentation
you'll understand how you can read the
market a bit more clearer and you know
being a trader you want to understand
what you're looking at rather than just
taking trades based on an up arrow or
down arrow so without further ado let's
get started you're having problems
hearing me you might want to try let me
just eat you up hopefully that's better
turn it up sensitivity very high so what
you're going to learn today is what is
order flow how to read it in why it
matters how order flow reveals what the
market is doing how to effectively
manage trades with order flow and at the
end of I talk about two of my favorite
order flow trade setups with low risk
and high reward potential
so for those of you that are new to Who
I am and order flows my name is Michael
Altos and I've got over 25 years of real
world trading experience you know I
started on the eme trading floor in the
early 90s as a runner I started at the
bottom of the industry and after a few
years on the trading floor I realized
that electronic trading is going to be
the future of the market and I left the
trading floor and I started trading
upstairs with being Witter on eme had
Globex board of trade had practically
and nymex Comics had their own access
system and I was doing that for several
years and I joined another company in
Chicago called EDF an English trading
company after a few years there I joined
Commerce Bank from Commerce Bank I spent
three years as a UX trader
and
finally I joined Cargill Cargill you
know it's a big American trading company
and I spent four years there's a trading
desk manager and they even sent me out
to Singapore to set up trading desks
there in Singapore when the local
exchange was closing down and
join JP Morgan as vice president Futures
Trading I spent eight years there on the
trading desk trading in and out you know
trading every contract you can imagine
alright and after eight years there you
know of working ten twelve hour days I
had enough and I left JP Morgan and
want to spend more time with my family
you know that's what trading can do for
you it can let you spend more time with
your family and shortly you know the
next year I started trading for myself
and writing a book on trading okay and I
started order flows in 2015 but I have
been writing my book is starting in 2013
2014 right and at the end of this
presentation I will show you how to get
a copy of the book called trading order
flow you're not gonna get the actual
book you're going to get a digital
you're getting a link to download it 150
page well you know it's not one of these
little flimsy books you know that
there's 12 pages that you know people
offer for free you know this was sort of
my contribution to the trading world so
from writing my book you know and
training for myself I realized that the
software out there wasn't good enough
you know it's just basic software on
reading the order flow so I sat down
with the programmer that understood
order flow and we've created the order
foolish trader which ones on ninjatrader
ninja trader 8 now and it's a volume
footprint chart with additional
pre-programmed order flow indicator so
you can understand what you're looking
at in the market and
all the charts you see in this
presentation are generated using the
order flow trader software again you
know before I jump in a brief disclaimer
you know please understand that trading
is risky right risk capital this money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one financial security or lifestyle and
I just like to understand that because
there is risk involved in trading now
most of you that are familiar with
trading you'll understand that the
market trades in a two-way auction right
there's a bit and there's an offer and
but from that you have different types
of buyers and different types of sellers
okay you have people that fit on the bid
or below the bid those are passive
buyers people that sit on the offer
they're trying to sell our passive
sellers now for a trade to happen the
trader has to be aggressive
a seller has to sell at the market and
hit the bid and they are selling to a
passive buyer right a passive seller
sits on the offer and waiting for an
aggressive buyer to come into the market
I think of it like when you're trying to
sell your house right
you have you list your house right you
put it up for sale for whatever $250,000
right you are the passive seller you're
waiting for the buyers come to Dallas
yeah I like it and pay you know pay your
$250,000 now if a lot of people come to
your house see yes but you don't get any
you know people are interested to buy it
you know but you get somebody you know I
like your house but you know I don't
think it's worth 250,000 you know I'll
pay you a 200 thousand they're a
pacifier yes for a train to happen on
the house either that buyers going to
realize hey this is a nice house and
he's going to be aggressive and he's
going to pay the 250,000 or the seller
you think oh my gosh you know I showed
this house 200 people nobody likes it I
got some guy willing to buy it for
$200,000 tell us again you're going to
be aggressive seller
so interpreting what you see on the time
and sales you know other ones things
we'll have to look at more derful you
gotta read time in sales or the dome
like this is a definite market the price
letter here but you know it's like you
gotta be you know high a mathematician
but you got to be very quick and you
know understand the numbers that you're
looking at and you know it's all this
data it's a bit overwhelming you know
but what you know if you have all this
data and it moves so fast that if you
think you miss something important
what's the point right so that's why
having a chart that takes all that
information from the time and sales from
the depth of market everything that's
being traded in the market and put it in
a nice easy to read format that you can
understand what is happening in the
market right that's why you know when
people talk about order flow you know
there's this a silly argument where
people say well you know what you see on
a footprint chart that's already
that's not orderable because it's not
orders coming in and out of the market
that's being what's being traded well
what's more important actual trades
happening we're looking at a depth of
market right a price ladder with bids
and offers going in coming out coming
out be cancelled being moved higher
lower as opposed to things that actually
trade you know when you have trades
occurring someone is committed to a
position alright and what's more
important being committed to a position
where you're going to have to get out
sooner or later or people say you know
the market is six feet at seven but you
know there's a thousand at eight right
yeah of course you'd love to sell eight
if the market is you know six bit at
seven it's not going to happen till the
seven straight out then the seven start
trading out the thousand and eight is
gone and all of a sudden you know the
dynamics are shifting but if that
thousand at eight trade market spike
stop 2008 trade thousand and nine trade
it's going to show up on the footprint
chart and you could make good trading
decisions based on what just happened in
the market
now on a normal candlestick chart right
most traders are familiar with
candlesticks that's the first chart that
they use in trading and you can't really
tell areas of support or resistance
because you don't see the volume right
all you're seeing is the open high low
close but when you look deeper at the
order flow right you can see here as a
box going around here all right and why
you notice how the market comes back and
tested twice eventually it broke through
that support but if you're looking at
the order flow you'll see why right
because you have this is an area where
aggressive buyers stepped into the
market and we're aggressive the market
rallied up came off again rally back up
came off the second time
support health and this is what's called
market generated information right again
this information is available to
everybody and it's available on normal
data feeds right it says you don't need
level two data or level three data it's
just a simple level one data that you're
going to get from your broker with your
brokers with your trading account
to your broker now to get the most out
of order flow analysis you got to start
with the basics okay there's no there's
no point me jumping in to look for this
look for that without talking a little
bit about the basics of order flow
now there's three data point right com
the three building blocks Delta point of
control and imbalances and it's like
little pieces of you know Lego set you
galleys Lego spread out but you know
there's nothing formed with it and
eventually you make a nice house and
order flow is the same way you're taking
that information and you're putting it
where it belongs can make a good trading
decision
so the first thing I talk about is Delta
and that's the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar and Delta is important so you
know who is dominating the current
market has shown the bar and again it's
the difference between the volume traded
on the offer versus the volume traded on
the bid now every buyer is going to have
a delta and on most order flow charts
most volume footprint charge Delta is
going to be indicated along the bottom
of the bar so you'll have positive
Delta's which mean aggressive buyers
were in control of that bar some bars
gonna have negative deltas which means
sellers were in control of that bar and
once you understand once you start
putting together Delta over bars you
know the market really starts to click
for a lot of traders so sick of Delta
like you know you got this one woman
here armwrestling with three kids but
you think well there's their street kids
surely they can beat this woman but you
know if the woman's stronger then all
three combined you know the woman is
going to win now the second point of
order flow is point of control and point
of control in a bar is the price level
with the most volume you know there's no
mathematical formula to determine it
other than simple arithmetic every bar
is going to have a point of control you
know oftentimes traders like to think
that the more complicated as a equation
you have for figuring out the market the
better it is know you know stick to the
basics now corn and control every bar
has one just like Delta and again it's
the price level in the bar with the most
volume I just drew a few arrows on here
show you how it looks like on a volume
footprint chart and most volume
footprint charts will put a rectangle
around price level in the bar with the
most volume and again if the single
price level it's not measured diagonally
against the business the offer is set
one price level and point control think
of it as you know the point in the bar
with the most volume right you know it's
going to be think of it as your waist
basically you know the widest point on
the bar
now the third part is market imbalances
right and they occur when there are more
aggressive buyers and sellers or
vice-versa more aggressive sellers and
buyers in too late auction
and a buying imbalance occurs when
there's at least four times as many
traders find the offer than traders
selling the bids right and the selling a
balances the opposite it occurs when
there's at least four times as many
traders selling the bid then traders
buying the offer now not every bar is
going to have a marketing balance
but the ones that do it gives you
information as to what's happening in
the bark it's information that when you
start adding it with what you've seen a
find controls with what you see in the
Delta you can make some very astute
trading decisions now I just highlighted
a few in here you can see in the bar
right there's black numbers and there's
red numbers and blue numbers the black
numbers is just your normal order flow
going through the red numbers in a bar
indicates sound imbalances the blue
numbers inside the bar indicates spider
balances now some bars might not have
any minor selling the balances and some
bars might have a lot of sound
imbalances some bars might have a lot of
minor balances and occasionally you're
going to get some bars to have some
buying imbalances and some selling
imbalances again it really depends on
what's happening in the market now think
of it in balance this way okay you're
you're you're running into a big
elephant pushing you out of the way
right that's what it imbalance is
because you know your car versus the
elephant is not going to survive the
elephant is just much bigger and when
you see the aggressive sellers coming in
or the aggressive buyers it's telling
you something that's happening in the
market right now that you should be
paying attention to
now generally as the market Rises right
you're going to see mine imbalances
aggressive buyers are listing the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer demand is present generally the
opposite is true when you see selling
imbalances when a market Falls you're
going to see aggressive sellers are
selling into the best fit and looking
for the next next next best bid to sell
into because supply is present in the
market so now
understand Delta up on control and
imbalances what is order for how to read
it in why it matters right what's the
whole point of it
well order flow is the most current
information available to a trader right
it's not an indicator it's just the
market right what do you think is going
to be better to understand the market or
to understand what's happening on some
an indicator I could be taken
information from three hours ago or a
week ago
you know Oracle is not based on their
levels it's not Fibonacci not based on
the Elliot waves it's not based on MACD
not base I feel like not based on any
indicator nothing like that it's what is
trading on the bid
what's trading on the offer it's just
the market is it's hard sometimes for
people to understand because a lot of
traders get so indicator base that you
know they think that order flow is must
be some indicator it's not right this
was yesterday
right is the e-mini S&P all the charts
here today I'm showing you it just beam
in ESPs from yesterday and I think
there's a few from today okay so
remember yesterday or lunch time right
market was rallying up and you get to
this point here on the Left where you
sort of got is higher low there you got
a clear uptrend you got this pin bar
here you know the candlestick icon with
the pin bar you gotta buy it well what
are you going to do it looks a bit
foolish right you could almost draw a
nice trend line up here from these lows
it looks like it's holding this no
higher lows are being rejected but if
you're looking at the order flow
you can understand that the market is
kind of cresting out right right up here
on this lower high here right before
these two bars that are set at the
rectangle around it if you're looking at
the Delta right what do you see all
right you're going into a swing high the
lower high Delta is decreasing right you
want some four thirty which are strong
the next bar which is up which is just
three fifty one then your swing high -
fifty six get - built on a swing height
right at the divergence and then the
next bar it gets stronger negative 83
next bar - 163 next bar once you're
inside that rectangle - three ninety
three and you also have stacked
imbalances you got a lot of styling and
balances as you're coming off this
little bump back up right and then what
happened 15 points fell off right there
but if you're looking here you know you
think of a you know what we're in an
uptrend why should I be getting short
you know maybe I should be reloading
buying more on the dip but if you're
reading the order flow it's going to
help tell you that you know what we're
not going higher then you look like
we're going to go lower you know you
want to be taking trades that have big
potential and so you got nowhere to buy
nowhere to sell
how order flow reveals what the market
is doing right and the way I like to
describe it you know people say what's
like having an x-ray into the market I
like to think of it it's like treating
no hidden things on a map right you know
invisible ink under normal light under
UV light because you can see
what's really happening you know it
helps you see what the big players are
doing in the market right and you know
if people the oil is to run into this
explanation years ago when I was trading
at JPMorgan it will get these new
traders they think they'd have to know
everything
well I'll say you know not like where
you take an exam you have to have
everything memorized today you could go
back you could reference me
right and again this is yesterday
afternoon on that set sell op right now
you get three point eight point three
point D you know three potential areas
you could have been buying and you know
which one do you buy right what you want
to be taking a nice low risk trade and
ideally you want to be taken at a trade
that's not going to give you much
drawdown not much heat against you as
soon as you get into that trade you know
so you're wondering a B or C you know if
you've got a market just sort of went
sideways came out with its top
throughout piggy market would have went
sideways we also see these the one that
works but I'll explain it here so point
a right you can just see this market is
going sideways and you don't see
anything really strong in the Delta
telling you you know a usually buying
aggressive buyers are coming in we just
had a 15-point fell off
if the big players thought price was
cheap they would be coming in you'd be
seen address of buying be seeing a lot
of buying and balances you'd be seeing a
lot of strong positive Delta but instead
you just seen you know and also flipping
back and forth positive negative
positive negative positive negative and
kind of small you know 24 152 again to
be moving away from this what if this
was going to be a swing low right you
could be want to see you know some
strong conviction you know it sort of
look like you got it you know coming in
here when you have the stack find a
balance but it just didn't materialize
and then it would have gone and stopped
you out now point B again you know it
looked like the market was getting ready
to take off and then just one site
you've got two big green candles here on
the left with you know some nice
positive Delta
so nice buying and balances had nothing
in the order flow following that alright
so you have you know a potential trigger
right here with the two nice green bars
nice positive Delta's or the controls
are higher but what's happening in the
order flow afterwards nothing is just
dying on you it's just flat lining right
in just go sideways you notice that your
shine to be getting out of the market
right because the markets not making the
move that you were expecting you know I
talked about this a little bit later but
one of the reasons a lot of traders may
fail on the market but don't reach their
true potential is because you know
nowadays everyone wants to back test
everything or optimize and take profits
and a top level and they're going to
live and die by that like we have to go
to my take profit level or or it's not
going to get stopped out and just chalk
it up and move on to the next trade so
you know professional traders I know
because I've been one that I've worked
with almost a hundred thousands but you
know a lot of them and you're always
reassessing what's happening in the
market after you get in the trade
the trade isn't giving you that that
follow-through then conditions have
changed from why you got into the market
you don't know what changed you know
especially now the way this market is
you remember what they would market move
so fast sometimes I forget but what was
it Sunday night I think you know you had
a big sell-off on you know the China
trade talks
following through that market rebounded
back lots of times use the mikerickson
get these big moves and you're not to
know what happened until after the fact
so if you're waiting for later for this
market to move to confirm it rather than
reading what's happening in the market
that you can get out now because the
markets not doing what you expected
you're going to suffer right if you're
reading the market okay well I got a lot
of bullish buying here the bulletin
buying for the market to rally needs to
continue instead it just flatlines on
you you see aggressive selling that's
not a good sign now
the third point point see the third
level what do you have you got your low
coming in here right and you got some
effects strong-smelling coming into
those lows you can see the deltas - 1300
on the bottom in the box here - $6.99 -
723 then - - 11 - 78-75 these bars are
turning green they're going up point to
control one two three a bit higher
each bar from right after the swing low
is made so what's happened right we're
coming down strong selling you hit the
low we're selling
okay imagine you know think about it
coming into the market once all the
sellers are removed from the market
right yeah earlier you had thirteen
hundred seven hundred seventeen hundred
now all the sudden you got just two
eleven in the next bar just seventy
eight that's nothing 75 that's nothing
you know on bars that normally put in
five hundred to a thousand in Delta and
then they got these three little bars
there right people i talked about
absorption you can see absorption but
problem is you can't see
it's happening on a normal candlestick
cart or a bar chart because you're not
looking at the volume that's being
traded you're just making a guess then
the bar right after these three little
bars this big green bar big positive
Delta higher point of control
1 2 3 4 5 buying imbalances in the bar
and it's off to the races right the
10-point rally obviously after this big
green bar but after seeing what was
happening in these three little bars
that should have been your clue already
to strap it in get ready for a potential
move higher because the spelling that
was happening on the way down is no
longer there the sellers are gone
they've been removed from the market
right now all these people that were
selling things as markets going down
they're buying here like to buying on a
big green bar right what's happening on
the way down
you've got aggressive sellers right you
got selling imbalances this bar has got
three this bar has got sick
as far as got to okay then once these
sellers realize they're wrong where they
come in coming in here buying it back
they're starting to buy it back in these
other bars they're just for nothing
volume it counteracts the aggressive
selling the aggressive find that the bar
turns higher you can see the volume in
here it's pretty evenly distributed
between aggressive selling and
aggressive buying prices the deltas just
minus 75 on a bar that's traded five and
a half thousand contracts now then the
next bar obviously make positive Delta
at 8:43
multiple buying imbalances so you can
see how this market has shifted from
aggressive selling to aggressive line
and it happens immediately preceding
this very quick 25 minute rally of 10
points so
the third point I want to talk about is
how to effectively manage trays with
order flow right and you know sometimes
trading feels like you're juggling
chainsaws or knives or something because
you got to be looking at different
things that's happening in the market
right now in my over 25 years of trading
and working alongside festival traders
one of the big reasons they were
successful let's do two active trade
management you know everyone always says
he's got to have a trading plan you got
to have a trading plan all that really
and then they just talk about what you
have to do before you get into a tree
you don't really talk about after you
get into the trade right because they
think that well I'll just put a stop and
take profit border is right don't just
let the market stop you out so hit me
take profit you know know when a move
has lost its momentum okay this was
yesterday morning right after we hit the
low the early lows in the S&P right we
rallied up office so you have a
divergence right you have a new low with
aggressive buying a positive Delta
that's what's called the divergence the
new low with a great you know with
positive Delta which is kind of
aggressive mine you've got three buying
imbalances and they pick a name this is
the move right this move I'm waiting for
you know there's also some scope and you
know you get long somewhere in here 37 6
or somewhere in this next bar and take
an edit sit I'm going to you know write
this up you know 10 points or higher but
then we just sort of go up and then you
hit the sideways action now some traders
will say well yeah I could read that I
could see what you got to read bars
let's assign for me to get out whatever
but if you're reading the order flow you
can see what's happening right you have
your point of control
basically in three bars coming in right
around 30 81 and a half okay point of
control again the most volume level in
the bark and when you have several bars
put together it could act as support or
resistance so now I know we can't really
rally and put in a new higher point of
control which is not a good sign of
market debt if you expecting to rally
right and then you got a couple bars
with lower points of control one bar
back up here then the next bar below
next bar below you're looking at the
deltas you come up here to the swing
high you have to make others belts on
the swing high here but then the next
bar negative three for the next bar
after that negative three 90 and you
know you've got a couple positive 373
369 and then negative 252 negative 358
before the market sells off back to
where you got in now if you're getting
in here you know off the next bar off
this low you get into here at 1376 you
got a 10-point take profit your stop
you know maybe below the low 69 or
something and you're seeing this market
sort of stalling up here you know around
the 81-82 area and you're reading what's
happening in the points of control
there's nothing really one way or the
other in imbalances but the deltas are
kind of mixed right you're not seeing
strong positive Delta's if you're
expecting this market to go up instead
they're kind of mix then the market sort
of comes back down to your entry price
and then lower lower in the next thing
you know it's below your entry and the
trade you know in the red before you
know essentially runs to your staff
nothing you know realize people don't
realize risk can be defined but you can
determine how much you're going to risk
on a trade
but rewarded not so easily defined I
need active trade management okay and
what that means is you know so you have
your swing alright you got this big you
know move up here
right and then it goes sideways in this
pot and if you're getting long you know
I sort of have this area in here on 3034
area it may be got a little bit early
you know between 31 32 but you know if
you're long at work know somewhere
around in here around 30 34 market goes
up just starts drifting down you're
still in the money now this is one of
the things that separates good traders
from not so good traders is your long at
thirty thirty four market goes up to
thirty forty two again you have your ten
point take profit okay so maybe just
right up here right up skill set up
within a point and a half of your take
profit thirty forty four and then it
comes off it comes off in forty two
forty two thirty nine down to 37 now
your long as thirty forty second what
your haters
sign-ups I'm still in the money on this
trade right but
trades can turn into losers but if you
can read what's happening and understand
what's happening in this order flow
you're not going to be blinded by well
up steal the money to trade so on the
money I'm fine with it
okay well would you be fine with you
know the trade losing money
no of course not you know we all keep
that we've all been in that position
where you get into a trade to insist it
in the money for a long time and then
also next thing you know it turns into a
loser right so what's happening in the
order flow is if you're looking right
you're getting along here alerts as long
here around the 34 any of these bars
okay then you get up your swing hide it
just sort of goes sideways you're still
in the money
now you don't want to get out with trade
a lot of traders why don't I get out I'm
still two points three points in the
money and why should I get out but if
you're looking at the order flow you
just seen a lot of negative Delta's 120
to minus 43 minus 196 you know - 211 -
367 and even the positive Delta's that
you're seeing aren't that strong 104 and
450 strong - 14 that's not very strong
then 131
yeah on the move up you're seeing nice
strong deltas 801 426 844 92 then I'll
sort of stalled on you it sort of hits
this weak area
then the Sun comes in and the market
drops down it drops down to lower you
know drops down to your entry price you
break-even price and because even lower
and especially what it stopped you out
so why not get out up in here when the
order flow isn't giving you a sign that
you know this moves and continue up
right most traders are supposed to say
well I'm in the money I just let it go
back off I'll move my stop up to you
know break even and you know if I get
stopped out at breakeven I'm happy with
it well why if you can understand what's
happening in the market up here at 40
and 39 you get out you know plus three
or four points that's better than taking
a scratch on the trade or even taking a
loss no trace don't always go to your
target you know learn to take what the
market gives you so when we talk about
now two of my order flows favorite order
flow trade setup set have low risk and
high reward potential now the first one
is called the Delta surge and what it is
is the steady increase in directional
Delta over several bars and again you
know take it in context don't just say
well you have a Delta search right here
you know a bullish one after the market
is rally twenty-point right if I market
rallies 20 points you should be looking
for potential reason to short rather
than get long again after 20 point rally
that's what I mean by taking it in
context of the market now as I say that
this was yesterday morning in the e-mini
okay so market was you know we bounced
up off our lows
our low was at this time was like sixty
sixty-nine or 68 and 3/4 rally you know
13 points up then you start coming down
into the lows
okay so we're still good six points up
but we hit a swing high and then you see
the Delta is getting stronger - 252 -
358 - 924 that's before this big red bar
here so you know that this swing high
here is a bit weak and then you see the
aggressive selling coming in getting
stronger right then you push down into
new lows over the next two bars next
three bars oops
seven points down did pop back up sort
of where your entry was before falling
over and continuing on down but really
the sign was right here right before
this big red candle down again yesterday
in the minis this was a little bit later
about 10:30
just before both sides of 10:30
coming into the low and you see the
aggressive buying coming in you know
that's so I think it's one of my
favorite races my favorite trade is
because you're at your low and you seen
aggressive buyers stepping up into the
market okay and you can see it here 76 4
1 3 7 21 the Delta is getting stronger
all right then the market moves up from
the 45 area up into the 50s and just
sort of goes sideways back and forth
it's just rotating around here then two
minutes later the aggressive styling
comes into the market okay you can see
here - 408 - 5 11 - 12 84 all right then
the market again smells awesome but from
the 41 area let's pull back up to 40 44
3 quarters before pawn off - you know
the 36 and a quarter 37 area
you
and this was a little bit later you know
about an hour later we start going
sideways here in the market you can see
you know market rate between 35 and 38
but then the aggressive buying starts
building up to 108 203 3 1 7 right in
this boxes here ok and even the third
bar in here it's got 1 2 3 4 buying
imbalances ok so what do you have you
know endpoints and controls are higher
this one point of control is colored
blue color is one of the features of
software will color is certain points of
control which act as support or
resistance
and so you got a lot of bullish things
going on here in the order flow right
before the market popped up quick eight
points over the next five minutes all
right and if all that information is
right there in front of you based on
what's happening in the market right you
can see the aggressive buyers coming in
you see the marks going sideways going
nowhere and then BOOM puts in a support
area put in a bar that's got support in
it right then you see the aggressive
buyers kind of hidden in there it looks
like we're going a little bit sideways
but the aggressive buyers are
sequentially getting stronger then the
market gets the multiple imbalances one
two three four imbalances in this bar
even the next bar also that we line
imbalances next market for as its market
keeps moving higher
so that's what the Delta surges now
actually you can get it for free on my
website is the Delta surge isn't a
footprint chart it will run on a normal
bar chart as well as a footprint chart
and you just got to go to my website
entering your email and download it in
there I've got some videos on YouTube on
it now the second when my favorite trade
setups is I call multiple imbalances and
what it is is when three or more binding
balances in an up bar or green candle up
here or in a down red candle three or
more stellen imbalances appear and again
take it in context of the market right I
want to be looking to buy after a sell
off I want to be looking to sell after a
rally
and this one is part of my foot in my
footprint chart right it will put a box
a pink box the exchange color around a
bar that has multiple buying imbalances
a green up candle or a down red candle
that has three or more spelling
imbalances and you can see right again
in context preferably of the market
you're at a swing high up here and
you've seen multiple style bells now if
you're just looking for tax imbalances
like you have on the third red candle
over here on the right okay that's the
only stacked imbalance right most
traders are taught to look for stacks on
the balance okay plus there's going to
be times where you're going to get a lot
of buying imbalances or a lot of
spelling imbalances there aren't neatly
stacked on top of each other and think
about it
right here at the swing high you have
multiple sound imbalances not so later
at a lower price that you see continued
aggressive selling coming into the
market know about you know just slightly
lower than initially than this first bar
so think about it if you're just looking
for the stacks on a belt yeah okay I got
one here that's great
but you're going to miss getting in
earlier on the street and obviously on
this move up here you're not even going
to see you know visual stack buying
imbalances in here right because these
are not deck neatly one on top of each
other right there's a price level in
there with normal order flow so it's
you're going to miss trade and when I
say take it in context of the market but
you don't just buy every bar that's got
multiple body balances or sell every bar
that's got multiple style imbalances put
it in context of the market here you're
at your low of the dais with this red
line there's thirty sixty nine and you
see aggressive buyers coming in like you
got rebinding balances like before the
market rallies from 74 all the way up
into the 80
not be looking for stacked imbalances
you don't see anything here right
because the imbalances are sporadic
right there they're spread out right
again
listen to what the market is telling you
if mark is telling you hey we're at a
low and you see aggressive buying coming
in that's good information and if you
just looking for stacking boxes you're
not going to get those three but
multiple imbalances
is important in the market
you know a lot of bars have just one
maybe two buying the balances which
again you know doesn't necessarily mean
anything but when you have a bar is that
more than three three or more preferably
that means something generally I need to
aggressive buyers are active here's
another one this was yesterday again
you're coming into the low swinging a
little rather then right after the low
you got one bar three minor balances the
next bar for buying imbalances two bars
go sideways and then the next bar one
two three four five minor balances right
a little bit later another bar one two
three four five more my imbalances right
even on the way down your seams the bars
with the stone and balances and again if
you're just looking at stacked on a
balance or stack buying a balance is
you're not going to see this information
but you're seeing it by having a
software that's highlighting it to you
that's what my portcullis trader
software does is it highlights it to me
so I could make faster trading decisions
and smarter trading decisions so order
for
Alyce's provides the trainer advanced
information that they need to gain an
edge over other traders they want
they've got have an edge when your trade
they don't really go into giving you an
edge so you don't go out find it
yourself
well I'm showing you how by reading the
order file you can gain an edge because
you're going to understand what you see
in the market based on what's happening
that other traders aren't looking for in
the market so hopefully you can see how
powerful or derful analysis is right you
don't need to overcomplicate trading
again you know and a lot of people think
that I got have all these indicators or
you know I got a use some fancy
mathematical equation to figure out what
the market is doing H trade what's
happening based on what's being traded
in the market based on what's happening
right in front of you so if you found
this helpful I have a software package
the Oracles trader 2.0 software package
which makes order full analysis really
easy right so hopefully you know you can
see the power in order flow analysis so
you know whoever's ready for Oracle
analysis and ready to add it into their
trading self now is the time and there's
two ways you can do it you can get you
know get a free software out there
they're at our free footprint charts out
there try and learn order flow on your
own you can spend years looking at a
screen trying to figure out order flow I
think most people have lives so you got
your family you've got a job and you
just don't have hours a day to sit in
front of the screen trying to figure out
order flow and more importantly a lot of
people
don't want to waste their money trading
not understanding what's happening in
the market right I always see people
saying oh I blew up in a column yeah I
blew up you know this training combine
I'll just reset it
you're wasting your money right learn
the right way to trade from the
beginning rather than trying to figure
things out on your own right you know my
wife buys IKEA furniture and tells me to
put it together I want to read the
instructions oh no I just steal yours
the pieces put it together well whatever
I do that I always put things on in the
wrong spot or use the long screw it put
things in backwards and let me get you
know let me read the instructions let me
educate myself on how to put this
together before I start to do it you
know second way you can learn order flow
is get the education and software from a
trader let successfully trade it order
flow at the highest level for decades
get the massive trading losses give the
waste of time trying to figure out
everything on your own now the order
foolish trader again it runs on
ninjatrader eight now which is fine
because you know you have a futures
account it will work on Forex and stocks
that have a lot of volume and it's my
volume footprint chart with seven
pre-programmed order file indicates I
talked about one today right I talked
about the multiple imbalances I get my
chart template also show you think you
know if you want to set a chart up from
scratch but I thinking about two minutes
normally I sell it for $8.99 but again
having order flow software's one thing
the next thing is knowing how to use it
and I don't just give you the software
send you on your way
I provide a lot of education on how to
trade with order flow because you know
the markets are dynamic they keep
changing disease and you know sometimes
they'll people just want to try and pick
one little piece of order flow out well
these people that understand order flow
in general can do that but if you don't
really understand what makes the market
tick you're going to struggle a bit
now each week I do a private live group
training session for users right you
can't attend you can watch the
recordings right now I think it's but
how many sessions there are goes back
you know two years there's probably
about 77 videos up there and you can
watch them at your leisure if you can't
attend mine is recorded you know other
people they may charge you they want to
try to extra for something like this I
give it to you for free the weekly group
training just come into the room your
sense you know the afternoon of the
training it's held Tuesday nights at 7
p.m. Central time again if you can't
attend you can watch 3:40 but if you
want to attend live and ask questions
there you can do that right every week I
do it unless you know it's like some
major holiday or something and further
your education even more I'll give you
access to my order foolish trading
course which is 297 dollars I get it for
free there's 20 lessons 15 hours of
video instruction and for those that
really want to jump into a sort of the
deep dive into order floki access to my
inner circle videos right there's 56
videos I recorded over the years I
advanced order full of tricks tips and
analysis right again if I don't even
offer this for sale but when I did it
was 497 just for the videos you can get
access to that for free
so when you add up with the software is
all the training you know it's quite
expensive right 1693 but I don't want
you to pay that and I even got a special
bonus for you my order folks a book
right which is I got ten trade set up
scenario on my additional favorite trade
setups
and nor do I sell that course for 297 so
you're looking at you know close to
$2,000 for all this but I'm not going to
charge you that but I want you to
understand what you're getting right
this is what other people have said
about software Mike your order folks
trader software is remarkably helpful
because I can clearly see what is
happening now in the market like for
example who's in control the market on a
very specific time
you know other traders say excuse me
you know this is very true guys you know
if you really want to trade properly
understand what on earth is happening
the markets Porter flow is a path
forward and my experience and
explanation is click so you know another
person says you know I took the course
alone one month ago and give a really
fresh it aim airfield in the field very
impressed so think about it right if you
want to become successful you have
planted you know you have to just fall
on your left you have to figure out what
you're going to do stop successful and
that's why I has this package for you
right it's just a one-time payment 675
go to order flows comm flash off to no
future payment you know upgrades are
free we've got a big upgrade coming out
later this year you do have to pay
obviously your data fees you know in
NinjaTrader fee this software runs on
the free version energy trader as well
as a version and you know if you have a
brokerage account but you know a ninja
trader or one of their other brokers you
can get actually a real kind data feed
or very inexpensive monstrous price as
opposed to pay a higher fee so all you
guys do not just go to order photos.com
slash off to tasty to this page scroll
down you can see down at the bottom
there's some videos there if you want to
watch the videos and explanation on how
to read order pro let's go to this
button I want this I click on that takes
it of PayPal okay I don't get your
credit card information I don't want
your credit card information
I'll handle by PayPal
information they're pretty much
everybody's got a PayPal again if you
don't have a PayPal comp you could still
pay through PayPal with a normal debit
or credit card now for those of you that
speck around that are interested in
getting my book go to order Flo's calm
slash book dot html' you'll have to
enter your name and email address then
you hit submit
and it will take you to the page
afterwards where you can download the
book ok again it's the full book it's
not an abridged version it's not a
best-of in special book that I wrote on
training order file you know it's even
been translated is Chinese done right
before the coronavirus but um
you know it's great book right even if
you don't want my software you already
trained with order for someplace else
fine read my book see what you get out
of it
become a better trader so you got a X
now I go to order clothes complex off to
that HTML you know we just been on this
whole coronavirus lockdown it's been a
great time to learn new things and not
everyone's talking about oh my gosh
we're going to shut down something again
and you know it's going to be worse
there's a lot of fear-mongering you know
imagine what happens if we go into a
depression
right what skills do you have to put
food on your table
Isis
to pay for your house you know if you
know how to trade you have money in your
train account you can trade right if you
have a job that's dependent on the
economy good luck
you know hopefully you won't lose your
job you won't lose your house and you
can you know have food but no trading is
one of those things you can trade it
from anywhere in the world and if you're
good and what you're doing you have a
source of income so you know I don't
want to promise that everyone's going to
be successful trading is not for
everybody but for those that apply
themselves and want to become better at
trading you can do it so thanks you know
go to order folks calm slice off - to
find out more so you know a couple
questions I normally get
is
yes the is does it work on stock does it
work on for it yes it does we've got to
stick to the main stock so I can stop
the trade volume right because there's
no point in trying to analyze volume of
the stock that doesn't trade a lot of
volume the same thing with Forex you'll
stick to major pairs sometimes you know
I involved you know a lot of groups
right and I think things people postgame
Singapore Canadian dollar I live in
Singapore for ten years I love anybody
the trade is Singaporean one guy trading
Singapore Canadian dollar and he was a
Canadian guy and traveled actually
needed train say some currency back into
it but you know to fix to the main pairs
euro USD Japanese vs. dollar you know in
their futures contract on those and one
port leaders that have no micro futures
contract on that so you can
you can get all that information on my
website to see you know what markets are
good for trading you know I have a
youtube channel go to youtube about two
hundred and sixty videos so in just how
many videos on order flow analysis again
you know you can start there people I
guess where's the best place to start
you can do it right there right so
thanks everybody again you know thanks
for your time
some people are saying that the link
doesn't work it does work I've tested it
earlier before got to make sure you put
the a dot HTML on the end you know some
people saying they have a web page block
you know if you know I don't know why
you have it maybe your security settings
are very tight
doesn't come up online and I've got
several computers you know for trading
and for other things everything works
fine so thanks for your time everybody
and again you know any questions let me
know and send me an email it's my cat
order photos comic just one quick side
note I get several hundred emails a day
over a lot of things so sometimes it may
take me you know day to get back to you
but you know I try to get back to
reasonable reasonable questions that
have a lot of information that makes you
know send me an email or will this work
the Indian market okay that's a very
general question you know kinds and make
it a little bit specific
that's like saying will this work on the
US market yeah work on the US market now
obviously it works I guess you know I
trade it and you know several hundred
other people trade it and you know try
to understand again you want to send me
a question be a little specific on your
trading style you know because sometimes
people say does it work on this market
but they're trading for our chart it's
probably more so is going to be very
effective on the longer-term charts you
know it's more effective for shorter
term traders I don't want these scalpers
but you know people with a timeframe
below one hour really benefit most from
order flow so thanks Kathy
thanks everybody I'm going to
so have a great weekend again any
questions feel free to email so go to
order closed calm where Helle oh I'm not
going to talk about the other indicators
today I just don't have time to get into
it that's literally whole nother
presentation but I do have a lot of
videos explaining them on YouTube so
feel free to send me an email
might get order flows thanks Kathy and
have a great day everybody
you
[Applause]
everyone oh I thank you for coming to
online charger special tonight our kind
thanks to our host Mike Val toes Mike
ass sign order flows calm the links are
working I test them they work fine plus
Norton I don't know Norton can be a
little weird sometimes but try putting
them AC PS and then the link and then
you probably make Norton all happy but
anyway ah I want to thank you all for
coming out we know that time is that
commodity they're not out there trading
on the Internet it's one of those things
I'm hoping that some days somebody's
going to come up with a cutting machine
because I could do with a three-day
weekend and a four-day work way wouldn't
that be wonderful everyone thank you for
your time your participation very polite
and wonderful audience today and a great
host Mike and border flows comm you see
bit blink there for your free ebook and
to subscribe to the software it's order
flows calm that's plural order flows
calm board / oft to dot html' okay if
you have any questions email it directly
blank at border flows calm good night
everyone have a great night ahead
good day trading
[Applause]